welcome to the podcast my guests today
are arthur jones and giorgio angelini
they are the filmmakers behind a new
documentary
called feels good man it's definitely
one of my favorite films of the year
it's an absolutely
wild insane ride this is a phenomenal
conversation
about many interesting things including
internet culture
i think you're going to enjoy it so hit
that subscribe button and
that's it enjoy the conversation feels
good man
[Music]
welcome gentlemen i'm super happy to
have you guys here today
very happy to be here yeah thank you um
i love
the movie i truly think it's one of the
best documentaries of the year
so it's exciting to break it down with
you guys today and i think
first we should we should kind of
synopsize it for people that have not
seen the movie so
i guess i can allow you guys sure
the opportunity to tell us a little bit
about the movie you'd think after like
months of explaining this we'd be really
good at it but it's always very
nerve-wracking to be like what is this
movie actually about it really
definitely
specifically what it's about i mean
there's things that it's about on the
surface
but what the real what the movie is
really about is what's going on you know
beneath that
veneer of what's happening specifically
with pepe the fraud
exactly yeah and i mean i think it's
that complexity that drew us to the
story
initially but you know the the inciting
incident for the movie
is a pretty simple and kind of weird
thing it's a single panel of an obscure
comic book called boys club and um
there's this one panel in which
pepe the frog which is this
anthropomorphic stone green frog
character that if you haven't seen pepe
the frog you just stop the podcast
and then google it and then immediately
come back close that tab you know come
back in two weeks
yeah you finally wrap your head around
what exactly is going on after you've
taken a disinfectant shower
then come back to the podcast but um so
there's this one panel of this comic
that's done by matt fury who's the
subject of our documentary
and in this panel pepe is saying feels
good man
and um it's this one single image of
pepe that was cut and paste out of that
image and then became this like viral
phenomenon globally and
our story tells the very like strange
and unlikely journey
of this comic book character becoming an
internet meme that was wildly popular
and then ultimately becoming sort of a
tool and a
propaganda sort of tool for the
alt-right and officially designated a
hate symbol by the anti-defamation
league in late 2016
and the story is kind of two-fold it's
the story of matt fury who created this
with no ill intent
obviously it becoming a meme and then a
hate symbol had nothing to do with him
and it's a story of him sort of
realizing that and then dealing with it
in the ways that he felt were
correct to him and then the other part
of the story is about how trolling moved
off of message boards
and into mainstream politics because
pepe was really used as basically a tool
for trolls
and so um when we started making the
film we realized that this could be like
a really unique story because
the way that pepe was sort of like taken
from matt was a way that we felt like a
lot of viewers would potentially see
consensus reality sort of being stolen
from them
in the attention economy right and so um
it was something that
also myself as a cartoonist was excited
to just
have a movie that talked about cartoons
seriously right you know in the way that
like cartoons carry all of this kind of
like
visual baggage to them um that they're
that they are these things that are like
intellectually sticky that people often
sort of dismiss but
you know they're they're important and
potent and stay with us for decades and
pepe was this
i don't know emotionally flexible avatar
that people were using
and speaking of uh cartoons seriously
and
as important as they are the the the
panel in which
pepe says feels good man is in response
to his friends making fun of him for
peeing with his pants around his ankle
right
so it's it's perhaps like the most
benign like innocent you know ridiculous
thing ever and the idea that that image
could get
co-opted and evolve over time into such
a
you know pernicious uh icon
of regressive culture is baffling right
and i just remember
personally the first time i came across
pepe the frog
late in the game was just seeing that
that
that emoji popping up on people's
twitter profiles and being used in
posts that were you know very much in
the alt-right bent
and being confused like why is this frog
being
aligned with this particular political
perspective
doing a little bit of research into it
but still not really
grocking what exactly was going on and
the story that you tell is just so much
more astounding
and exasperating than you could possibly
imagine
yeah i think that's that's sort of how i
understood pepe at the beginning
like i had spent a lot of time on reddit
in the early days and like was familiar
certainly with pepe as a meme
but when arthur told me that
he was starting this project like i it
came from a
relationship that he personally had with
matt and so like i felt
kind of totally embarrassed that i
didn't know anything about the backstory
but like
um in those first early conversations it
was just very clear that this was
such an incredible opportunity to tell
at least what i find like to be the most
interesting kind of documentaries that
are about
something on its face very specific and
eccentric and strange but really speak
to like a
broader cultural situation right yeah in
the broadest
sense it's about how um
about how information travels and shapes
culture
right through the lens of this one
specific
image but you know the idea
of the meme you know as it's as it's
most broadly defined and i love
this woman that you have on who you know
the color with all the crazy hair and
everything like that because she's a
character right and she's into like the
paranormal and all this
crazy stuff but um the idea that this
the idea of the meme hearkening back to
richard dawkins in this book that he
wrote that there are
genes that influence human behavior and
it's memes that influence cultural
behavior and
evolve over time to you know shape uh
not just
political philosophy and ideology but
cultural identity
and everything that gets packed into
that like the power of that
cannot be overstated and yet we kind of
think of memes as a very
you know kind of casual temporal thing
oh yeah we're just beginning to
understand like the true
grotesque potential what brands can do
both to like
coalesce political uh bodies but also
uh be deployed as political propaganda
there's just so much embedded within
the way images operate on the internet
um
yeah this is definitely at its core the
film is like
really a media study or media literacy
project right
yeah kind of in the back of my head when
we were starting at two i was observing
how
my father like i grew up in rural
missouri
and my very conservative family
evangelical right
yeah evangelical family southern
baptists and my dad had been like a bob
dole supporter he'd been like kind of a
family values conservative
and he's a very like moral guy like he's
never had a beer or a cigarette
you know he's someone that really walks
the walk
and um i would have thought that he
would have been
shocked and horrified by trump i would
have thought that he
would have found trump's morals to be
reprehensible
and um i was surprised that all of a
sudden he was really kind of
um completely enamored with trump and i
was also surprised how he just got an
iphone and wouldn't stop staring at it
um he was using the iphone like a
teenage girl like he was just scrolling
constantly the fox news media feed
and it was something that um i was
kind of trying to like think about and
deal with and even though none of that
is like in the film specifically
um that was the stuff that i was um
thinking about as we were beginning to
make the film how can we have this story
that's about these
um for me it was kind of like this twin
passion of like cartoons
and iconography and then also kind of
trying to decode what is going on
in in the country right and so um you
know those were the conversations that
giorgio and i were having about in the
beginning and
we thought pepe was just such just an
amazing vehicle for this large
discussion because ultimately we can
make a movie about this hilarious stoned
weird frog
and then we can sort of like within all
of that have all of this like
um really kind of important
informational stuff
that is pointing towards a seismic shift
in culture social media is changing
culture in a way that we're just
beginning to understand you know feels
good man is like a cave painting at the
beginning of a new
era right you know and i think it's just
like um
the way the internet is kind of like
downloading our psyches into the machine
is something we have to be aware of
and pepe is like a way in which we can
kind of like talk about it right it
doesn't feel like
overly intellectualized it doesn't feel
like
um uh you know too important it's still
this kind of like weird frog
right and um yeah it was just something
that
uh we just became completely obsessed
with over the two and a half years we
were making it
it also underscores just how strange the
whole thing is
because pepe is this bizarre you know
figure it's like it's this amazing entry
point to explore a very serious subject
with this veneer of kind of
lightness at the same time right so
you uh arthur your your background is as
a cartoonist yeah like yeah and graphic
designer so you were friends with matt
like take us back to i want to talk
about matt a little bit like and the
impetus for the film
sure you know at the outset well to go
back to the beginning is i i'd bought
his comic book boys club
at quimby's bookstore in chicago and
that's an independent bookstore
and um it was a pretty obscure comic
it's not a comic book store that you
would buy like a spider-man
you know an issue of spider-man at right
this was more of like a you know bespoke
kind of
indie store and i thought his comic was
really funny and i really liked it
and um it had stayed with me for several
years just kind of like in the back of
my head so when i
saw pepe start to pop up on the internet
i found it baffling i wondered if the
people who were using it had any
knowledge of its context or the comic
and then i met matt when i moved to
california through some mutual friends
he was friends with my girlfriend carrie
mclachlan who's a co-producer on the
film
and actually some of the archival
footage used and feels good man was
stuff that she had shot
and um we took a hike um to a hot
springs it took two days we hiked out
like 10 or 12 miles with a group of
friends
we stayed at hot springs overnight um
and then we like hiked back
and um it was something that matt and i
just bonded we bonded over cartoons
we bonded over um the things that we
were most excited about
and um then we started to um run into
each other
around los angeles and when i ran into
him i would try to figure out ways to
talk about pepe a little bit because i'd
see him in the news i'm like what do you
think about this and i could tell that
um matt's opinion about it was still
forming
it was something where initially i think
he just wanted to like ignore it
and he just figured this was just kind
of like part of the internet that he had
nothing to do with
and then as it started to get weirder
and weirder
he just kind of as a friend just asked
me for help
he could see that i was like maybe
thinking about this a lot
and that um he trusted me and so
initially we thought about
um trying to produce like a cartoon and
the cartoon would be sort of an updating
of boys club it would be we would take
that as sort of the initial source
material and then we would tell sort of
like
uh alice in wonderland kind of story
where pepe gets sucked out of the comic
book
and then into this like kind of
dystopian existence and he has to find
his way back home
and then um we pitched that around los
angeles and um
surprisingly no no one saw that but what
what's
part in the pepe evolution this is like
take place this is like 2015 so like
yeah
yeah so it's insane at this point yeah
it was 2016. it was a little bit insane
for us to
do it for sure right just because you
have to realize some
some people thought matt was somehow
like a member of the alt-right
right they would see his comics of
course and they would just all of a
sudden be like oh no
no we can't go there and that's the
thing that's baffling about the adl
stuff when
when pepe gets listed as a symbol of
hate speech
they put his name alongside it
which was confusing because then it
really did align him with that
and that had to be unbelievably painful
for him but couldn't they just get rid
of
the reference to him personally they
they've rewritten they have the
entry a number of times and you know the
adl has
you know we've talked to them at various
points during the making of the film and
they've been pretty generous with us i
i think um they were just kind of trying
to do what they felt was best in the
moment and did not think about the
repercussions i think the issues matt
had with is they just didn't reach out
to tell him that this was about to
happen and all of a sudden matt wakes up
one day
and he's a news item and um he
uh is obviously like horrified that his
name was attached to this and also it's
just like
he's trying to make he's trying to eke
his career out basically as an
independent cartoonist
and all of a sudden if you're the guy
that popularized the alt-right right
yeah you know if that's what people are
saying you're radioactive
completely completely and so um
you know that was another motivation for
us wanting to make the film was because
i just realized that
almost no one knew matt's story they did
not understand where pepe came from
and we thought that like if people
understood the true context for the
character and the backstory
that we would basically be able to like
um
you know we've talked we've talked about
it before is like kind of like um
canonized pepe so at least people would
know
that if they see a meme of pepe that's
not the original version
because there's been a lot of cartoons
that have been remixed
redrawn in really hateful ways like
there's a lot of like racist spongebob
on the internet but the difference is
that yeah the difference is that there's
a huge studio that created it and
everybody has a prior context for that
but boys club was this hidden little
thing that almost nobody knew about so
they didn't have that history to
contextualize the whole thing
no i mean it's kind of remarkable if you
look back on it as
you know the full uh totality of the
story like matt creates
pepe what in 20 2006 yeah
and i don't have the numbers but i would
guess that pepe is probably like in the
top 10 most recognizable cartoon images
across the world and it has
nothing to do with like a company just
you know
pumping billions of dollars into it as a
brand it's just purely in the power of
matt's initial image and its
ability to have like connected with a
particular audience online
right and just grown from there and you
know to mention like it started off
innocently and right
it really metastasized into something
much different but
like in a sense the film was trying to
reverse engineer
that context that in on the internet
in in the absence of that context like
the hive mind of the internet just kind
of injected its own narrative
into pepe and so i think we're happy
to see that in the release of the film
um it's kind of operated just as we
would have hoped that like it's really
um that's all matt's ever really wanted
to do is to tell his story not to like
i think sometimes he gets castigated by
certain trolls online for like
being naive about wanting to like take
back pepe i don't think right there's
not an interest in taking it back it's
just
telling a story right yeah i mean there
is a there is a narrative that
um he was somewhat naive and thinking
initially that you know it would just go
away
um until it gets so out of control that
he's you know
realized that he's got to step in and
and do something so
the underlying theme is really this
journey from passivity to participation
on behalf of matt specifically but also
on behalf of you know the 4chan
community and all these other people who
become activated to participate in the
political process in a way that
previously you know didn't didn't appeal
to them because of
feeling dis disenfranchised or whatever
so that's the real power the kind of
engine beneath the whole thing
that created this metastasized you know
icon and also you know the result of the
2016 election in so many ways
yeah i mean that's sort of alone in that
experience right there aren't really
many other artists that have had to
go through what he's gone through and so
he's really had to make up the game plan
along the way and so
um as documentary filmmakers it was
really a gift to be able to capture that
sort of coming off the proverbial couch
moment happening in real
time right to really track someone have
to confront
something that they thought would just
go away on its own and
really feel like they're kind of this
reluctant hero and that
as filmmakers was really potentially
powerful because i think for a lot of
americans they might see themselves in
him a bit
right like in the way that his artwork
was taken away from them they're
yeah like arthur just mentioned like
their sense of
making sense of the world of rhyme had
been taken away from yeah i mean
you see this guy you know this
expectation that he's going to hire a
lawyer the institute he finds out that
pepe
is you know being used in a way that he
didn't intend is
is preposterous it's like this is a you
know he's a very sensitive
you know artist seems like a really
sweet guy like that's just like not the
kind of guy who's going to do that
but also that stuff costs money you know
yeah yeah exactly
you know so a lot of money in a weird
way it had to get as bad as it got
and nobody could have predicted that
anyway exactly you know so i i think
it's
i understand why people might consider
matt naive but i think it's important to
point out that like
obviously this has never happened before
and pepe has outlived a lot of the
platforms it was even popular on
things on the internet do disappear and
pepe for whatever reason has stuck
around now for more than a decade
and so i think matt initially thinking
that it would go away the same way
myspace and friendster did made sense
and then also it's kind of important to
point out we document in the film is
that matt was a new father when all of
this was happening he was
a lot more concerned with providing for
his family and changing you know diapers
than necessarily taking on the alt-right
right and so um he just kind of didn't
have like the emotional or financial
bandwidth
to deal with it and so um
you know i think he's in the film he
realized at a certain point that um
this obviously had to he had to use
copyright because it was kind of the
only tool that he had but before that
he tried initially to reach out to his
artistic community to remix and
re-kind of meme pepe in a positive way
and i think that's the moment that
people often would say matt was naive
but i think
matt knew that going into it and it was
a way for him basically just to reach
out to his community in that moment and
say like hey i need help
yeah you know can you help me and it was
a way for him to
talk to his friends about it and then
for them to make artwork about it
and it was like a very earnest thing
yeah and ultimately something like 500
you know kind loving pepes emerged from
that
but you know that's a drop in the sea of
you know hundreds of millions of of you
know pernicious versions of that there's
that scene
near the end where he's in that like it
looks like kind of a think tank
situation in san francisco with all
these data scientists and they're
analyzing
hate speech on the internet and he says
there's like a hundred million
he's like i wish you luck with that but
you know it's basically like you know
this is this is not the way forward in
terms of like
shifting that perspective but it's a
shame that like it had to get to a point
that it reached such a fever pitch that
uh this very large and powerful
uh legal institution that wilmer hale
and louis tompros and stephanie lin were
able to come
help matt pro bono right like it had to
get to a point at which
a law firm could see a kind of greater
social good and donating their time to
help him
and without that i mean i don't know
where he would be and it was really like
uh i don't know it's bears mentioning
too that there was this break point
for matt where um uh
well i guess now no longer assistant
principal
of a middle school in texas had
published this right children's book
that had once again co-opted pepe but in
the context of like a pretty racist
yeah that seemed to be the the the you
know bridge too far where he really got
activated after that
yeah i mean it was it was propaganda
directed at four and five-year-olds
and um you know in the in the movie we
also showed that matt is a children's
book author
an illustrator um and i think he found
the fact that this propaganda was sort
of
being um pointed at such a young
audience as he found to be
really disturbing and it was also just
easily accessible on amazon
it wasn't just as simple as like asking
amazon to take down the book
and so you know we've even noticed that
like you know there's all
this bootleg pepe stuff that's on amazon
and it's actually quite hard to get them
to take it down
yeah you know none of this is like just
an easy process it takes a lot of time
and a lot of intentionality
and so um he realized that that was kind
of the moment that he needed just to
seek out help and yeah luckily he found
this law firm that was willing to do it
and they continue to kind of
um fight for pepe in various kind of
ways now
i love the euro shot of the lawyers
coming into the conference room
that got a standing ovation yeah
that was yeah that was an amazing moment
of sundance what did you do for sure
louis so the lewis the the main lawyer
there
was sitting just down the road at uh
sundance and
when the hero shot happens like what
happened i saw his wife like
reach over and like squeeze this yeah
yeah
there was but yeah it was a very
validating moment right for them to have
like this audience
uh because people are ready in the movie
for something to happen
right because we do sort of like well
because it goes to such a dark and
despairing place
you know and i was concerned about that
i was like how are you going to round
this out like i wasn't aware of how
it ended and that was quite uplifting
and interesting and
maybe we should we should leave that for
audiences to discuss
themselves but um but it is it does end
on a very hopeful note but i
i think what i'd like to do is is walk
through the
um a little bit of the timeline and the
evolution of pepe so that people can
you know wrap their heads or share and
make sure this happened i mean it
basically begins as you said with him
uploading a panel from his comic book to
myspace
it then seems to get adopted by
the the kind of fitness subculture on
the internet
who starts saying feel feels good man
after their workouts
which is an innocent and kind of fun
thing and were you able to
actually connect the dots from that back
to
matt well i mean nothing on the internet
is a straight line
it's sort of all spread out i mean you
know um we were
we weren't able to connect things back
to like certain people or certain sort
of moments on things but it did seem
like
um there were a few message boards um
that uh one one was about mushrooms and
that kind of made sense
and then there was another one that that
was bodybuilding.com's
um message board and for whatever reason
that message board has always had a
relationship to the fit message board on
4chan
um fit is often kind of a board that
will introduce like young guys to 4chan
because
it's guys who are like maybe like 13 or
and they're looking to just you know
kind of like shape up a little bit so
they'll go to fit and they'll sort of
like
you know talk to other young guys about
how to
lose weight how to gain muscle how to
basically just become men in the world
and so it seemed like that was probably
the moment that pepe passed from
the bodybuilding forum in the 4chan yeah
into the 4chan community i love what
we're talking about
tracing like yeah well it's it's you
know to extend the evolutionary analogy
that's like
you know the the the waterborne animal
finally climbing on the land you know
it's like a big
leap in in how this thing ends up
evolving well i mean there isn't an
emotionally linear line i mean i think
you can
correlate a lot of this you know
the inroad is through bodybuilding.com
but it like the metastasis happens
really in like um understanding the
kinds of people who are coming to those
kinds of forums right like there's
of course a huge number of people who
are there just to
seek out information but then there's
also like this
kind of uh other maybe more pernicious
cultural problem which is
of men who feel like they've been
scorned
specifically by women who are coming on
these boards to kind of share
a struggle and feel like they have to
improve their bodies and kind of
um like who kind of see the world and
maybe binary ways and feel like that the
only way that they compete
is through like improving themselves
physically
and you start to really see how like the
marrying of
the image of pepe and the sort of
catchphrase of feels good man and then
these
kind of nascent emotional problems all
kind of coalesce at that moment right
yeah and on on 4chan there's i mean it's
a lot of different message boards and
each one of them kind of have their own
little communities attached to them
but there's one message board in
particular named r9k
and this is a place where a lot of guys
would just go basically to kind of like
tell a story about their rejection they
would go there to talk about how maybe a
girl didn't sit next to them in the
cafeteria
or about how you know they'd had a
one-night stand and then they felt like
rejected afterwards
and pepe became the kind of like avatar
for that right
and it's an anonymous place people don't
use their faces or names and so pepe
became a stand-in for that
and so he went from the feels good man
frog to feel sad man frog
the symbol of rejection and so we used
um pepe basically has this like
emotional through line to tell the story
and as pepe got angrier the country was
getting angrier
you know the country was becoming a
place where
um you know outside of the mainstream
media
there was this aggrievement that was
becoming slightly irrational
and so we traced pepe from the feel sad
frog to the feels bad frog to the mad
frog to the smug frog to donald trump
and i know that sounds like a silly
narrative advice but it was powerful for
us
because ultimately we're trying to make
a film that tells this emotional
journey and the thing that's interesting
about pepe is how people felt attached
to the character
this jpeg really meant something to
people and when they started to see the
mainstream using it
it felt like a personal affront they
were like that's our thing right like
how dare you use our thing
this has been our safe space to share it
amongst ourselves
it's not for you and um
you know we found that to be interesting
like it surprised me going into it just
the connection that people were feeling
towards this frog
yeah um that was silly like as a way to
structure an otherwise super complicated
story it actually
as soon as we discovered that parallel
it became an incredibly powerful
narrative device and just like like
arthur just said just tracking
the descent of pepe into uh depravity
correlated so neatly with right and
really there's this watershed moment
that happens
in 2015 where there's in the span of two
weeks
you have a mass shooting at the umpqua
community college
in oregon which still today is the
deadliest mass shooting in oregon
history
and supposedly i mean this did happen
but we don't know for sure
if the shooter posted it but it's in all
likelihood
it seems very like on 4chan someone
posted the day before the shooting
uh a kind of warning don't come to this
school my 4chan friends whatever and
then it had at the bottom
it was an image of pepe holding a
handgun and then the next day the
shooting happened and then that was sort
of the first time that pepe
really made it into mainstream news
people referred to him as a grinch-like
creature yeah but but then two weeks
later and there was a little moment of
like pepe panic right right there were a
number of colleges that were like oh
right yeah you know that we're like
we're shutting we're shutting down
tomorrow because we've had this
anonymous like
threat it would be a pepe image holding
a gun or a pepe with a ski mask
yeah and then two weeks later we had
this moment where donald trump retweeted
an image of himself
and um as pepe yes he retreated he
retweeted an image of himself drawn as
smug pepe so his pepe with like the
yellow hair
standing behind the sort of podium as if
he was at a press conference
in the oval office or in the white house
and so um
and it seemed like the media wasn't kind
of connecting the dots between those two
things right
you'd have thought in an earlier era
that would have like um but unless you
were steeped in 4chan culture
you wouldn't be able to decode totally
exactly and that's exactly what it was
it was a wink it was sort of like his
a precursor to the kind of stand back
and stand by comment right it was a very
deliberate
use of a meme that was trying to
activate a certain group online who they
knew
was you know starting to gain momentum
as a support base for them right because
you have
all these kind of aggrieved men online
who otherwise it's kind of on its face
it's kind of ironic because like
they're people who presumably would get
bullied a lot in high school and like
here they are supporting someone who's
kind of like right the biggest bully of
all but for them it's like their own
bully
right and they share a sense of
common disdain for women people of color
pc culture specifically and so they like
rally around him and so that moment that
that donald trump tweets himself as smug
pepe is kind of like
yeah you're right it went completely
under the radar but it's actually an
incredibly significant moment that
really
the nature of politics and trolling just
become like completely
intertwined because the agreement that's
felt on on 4chan there's also kind of an
entitlement to it
people feel as though um in a previous
era
they would have had a much different
life they would have like met a girl in
high school they would have got a job in
their hometown
that the sort of like social options
that people have
now because of the internet means that
they will be out of work and unloved for
the rest of their lives
and this is sort of also happening in
parallel to obviously different parts of
the country feeling as though they're
being left out of the national
conversation
and that pop that growing population of
the aggrieved
uh coincides with the maturation of
these platforms that allow these
communities to congregate and you can
unite around these ideas
which is like you know that's a very
kind of powerful
machine that's humming in the background
that's basically
allowing all of this to percolate into
real life
totally i mean you see for example the
last
republican national convention i think
was the first time that
the party didn't put forth an actual
platform right it was just
if you watched it it was just like
unbridled unmitigated
anger and in this kind of situation that
we have now where there is no
political discernible political ideology
behind it the only way to coalesce
that body is through iconography and
like pepe really was became the first
vehicle through which that happens and
then i would argue like
pepe kind of lost its usefulness and
other things
filled in that vacuum whether it's like
queuing on and who knows what it's going
to be in 2021 but these are
this is kind of the world of politics
and memes that we're
having to confront right now well the
inflection point
where pepe tips uh from
4chan into broader internet culture
is super interesting you know and and
kind of backing
backing up from that you have this neat
culture right the
not in employment not in education
employment or training right which is
like the catchphrase for this 4chan
community
they claim ownership to pepe
and this is their kind of safe space for
their community right but the minute
pepe migrates outside of that
and people like nicki minaj and katy
perry
and these sort of you know beauty
youtubers are doing makeovers in the
likeness of pepe
that was the ultimate personal affront
to the 4chan community
and their reaction to that to protect
this symbol was to kind of defame it
themselves so that it
it couldn't be co-opted and used in any
other context so
it didn't germinate necessarily out of a
white supremacist
uh anti-semitic sensibility that
that image was marked up in that way to
prevent it from being
stolen and used in a way that they
didn't want it used
that's ultimately it ultimately becomes
a stand-in for that
ideology but that's not how it
originated
yeah i mean a lot of it came out of the
competition between 4chan and tumblr
and tumblr is not exact i mean it's
another image posting
site and it's a very inclusive community
at least it was at the time i mean
tumblr has kind of now faded away
a little bit but it was a very like
vibrant extremely
um you know uh diverse um
very feminist and they started to use
pepe and that was kind of the moment
that 4chan was like no no you can't go
there and so their response was actually
to kind of like literally smear pepe and
like there was this moment before pepe
became a nazi we don't get it into the
movie but it was just like the
scatological moment
where they're just do like drawing the
grossest weirdest
versions of pepe and so that wasn't
politicized in that moment
but then pepe kind of makes its way into
the politics board on 4chan
the poll board and that board was having
this moment where um it was getting very
fashion
it was getting like very fascist because
you had other things like gamergate and
other sort of
exacerbating events online that were
really serving to radicalize people in
real time
um but you're right i mean it's like a
big critique we'll get sometimes from
4chan people is like you guys normie
idiots like
pepe was never a nazi symbol the media
turned him in into that and it's like
well yeah i know we made the film and
like that we
we tend to agree with right but we need
that point it is also it is also the
case that it is like a hate symbol for
some people and that that switch
you're talking about is really important
one right because you have
a group of people who are kind of
responding to
the co-opting of their culture by by
mainstream culture which is fairly
typical i mean like in the punk movement
the same thing happened when like
basically walmart starts selling like
you know sex pistol shirts or whatever
yeah
but like um so that's kind of innocent
enough
but then you have the kind of
professional racist and opportunist to
see
in this a kind of opportunity to
take hold of this very powerful icon
that obviously
people care a lot about and the kind of
people that care about it
a lot are aggrieved young white men and
like
in the history and lineage of
professional racism like it's always
been about how to
find these out-of-work aggrieved young
white men
and tell them like where their problems
are coming from and how to solve them
and who to blame
right and like pepe was this perfect
kind of flag
that allowed these opportunists to
identify and
kind of radicalize them so you know both
things are true pepe is not a hate
symbol but also like
people were very eager to turn him into
one when you see
uh trump retweeting that image of him as
pepe
you know the immediate question that
comes to mind is what is his
self-awareness right around that at the
time like is he
consciously tapped into what that
represents
is he doing it because some somebody in
his campaign said
yeah you should retweet this like
where's his head at well
i feel like that's the problem you have
when like i've gotten into a lot of
conversations with trump supporters and
there's always this moment where they
have to acknowledge knowledge that
donald trump's a little crazy
they're like yeah yeah he just does some
crazy stuff sometimes but you know
i know he doesn't mean it and so i mean
he always has this plausible deniability
built into everything that he does
because we all assume that he's a little
like
unhinged or erratic or he's up on
adderall at two in the morning
whatever it is but we sort of are able
to explain away
all of the terrible stuff that he tweets
whether that's pepe or someone yelling
white power at the village's retirement
community in florida
um and so pepe is another one of these
you know
plausible deniability moments where it's
like we don't know we
can't understand what he thinks you know
but that's kind of baked into pepe
himself right like you've got the guy
forget his name who's like it's always
shrouded as a joke so you have that kind
of deniability as well like this doesn't
really mean anything
we don't intend it seriously because
it's all very
you know kind of uh
smug and and comedic right and this
again is like this
the part of the perfect storm you kind
of intimated it earlier is
is while these conversations are
happening online
it's the rise of social media as this
sort of incredibly powerful force
and what it what it serves to do in this
case is like
the culture of these boards is really
shrouded all and sort of irony jokes and
like you know
irony poisonings they call themselves
right and you're kind of trying to
one-up each other with
who can be the most depraved and the way
that 4chain works is it sort of rewards
that kind of
conversation it's really not that
dissimilar to
instagram it just has different inputs
right but they're both essentially
at the end of the day social media tools
that reward a certain kind of behavior
and for instagram it's like
you know posing on a yacht or whatever
that's going to kind of
foment the most fomo kind of reaction in
in the public and then on 4chan it's
like who can be the most depraved and so
that
that's going to be the edgiest you can
be the edgiest and so
yeah pepe becomes like a great way to
mask all of this
uh stuff and shrouded in this idea of
irony but
you know you start repeating the same
jokes over and over again and suddenly
it becomes a lot easier to believe these
things too right well you mentioned at
the very beginning the conversation this
sort of moment where frog twitter
happened and it was this blip before gab
popped up
where if you were someone who is
into trump a member of the alt-right you
would have a little frog emoji icon that
you would put in your twitter feed and
it was this moment that actually
politics was getting commodified on
twitter
on social media it was this moment where
all of a sudden politics had a certain
brand and
um all you know we are consuming these
entertainment products from fox news
from msnbc this is the team that we're
on this is my brand loyalty
i'm either frog twitter or i'm sjw
twitter or i'm rose twitter or whatever
and it's this sort of like taking on of
this like personal kind of
branding thing that um really kind of
flattens out the conversation
on social media and i think that people
were responding to kind of this kind of
knee-jerk
kind of consumerism attachment to
politics that was being
amplified on twitter during that moment
and you know pepe just became an easy
like wink wink
so on that subject of of trump's
awareness
or perhaps his campaign's awareness
around
this trend that's percolating up from a
dark corner of the internet
you've got this guy called uh matt
brainard who's
the data chief he's a strategist on the
on the trump campaign
um i think he was part of corey
lewandowski's staff right like
pretty high up in the campaign and this
guy's got like
voter data wired and he he see you're
shaking your head like
this is what i want to hear about like
because he comes off as pretty
tapped into uh you know how this whole
thing
kind of occurred and presented himself
in a way
that you know he was the chief architect
of making this happen
i think like everything that happens
virally on the internet i don't it's
very hard to
like take credit for things but he's
more than happy to do that
i think what i will say that was
important that he brought to the film
and why we wanted to talk to him was
really
explaining how like why memes were
powerful
specifically politically like he's the
one that puts forth this
really interesting idea that i think
we're still needing to contend with but
the idea that memes and politics has
the net effect of kind of democratizing
political media so if you're just a
single person sitting behind your
computer
in indiana and you create the right meme
and the president retweets it
all of a sudden you're like at the
forefront of the political conversation
that's unbelievably empowering
completely to the point that donald
trump himself recognized that and over
the last four years has hosted several
events with
like political members so like he's very
tapped in and aware of how
these narratives get built online and
how to
kind of take advantage of social media
in that way yeah and i think what
matt understood i mean matt is getting
his data the same place that like the
obama people got their data i mean if
you've canvassed for anyone in the last
you know
decade you know that they basically have
like winnowed it down to like who in the
household might be a swing voter
you know it's like they pretty much have
every single neighborhood
in america locked in on who votes for
who and when
and so he recognized that there was this
like
very slim margin that was there for
these people who were potentially open
to trump's message
i think that was something that he did
kind of understand pretty
early on that said you know i mean he
got
he got let go of the trump campaign when
they switched to to
steve bannon so i mean i think that
some of it was i just they catch they
caught the zeitgeist at the exact right
moment you know and that was something
that i don't think was like super
premeditated on his part
yeah you know but he did say you know
that like no one controls
trump's twitter feed except him you know
like trump is the person
you know in control of that completely
it's not like some group of guys they
they i'm sure at moments they were like
no no don't tweet that and then
there he was doing it right so well
bannon
exacerbates the whole thing and the
point is made in the movie
that um the whole position was that
the democratic party is not the
opposition it's the media that's the
opposition
and and that becomes a very you know
kind of powerful
idea that i think you know
allowed everything that you talk about
in the movie to
to be more potent than it would have
been otherwise and he also realized that
there had been this like incredible
there there had always been this growing
republican base connected to am radio
in america and that's a completely
factionalized and extremely angry group
of reactionary sort of um republicans
and it was something that i think the
mainstream republican party always kind
of viewed from a distance is like i
don't know if we want to totally go
there
like we know those people are out there
and we know that they're voting but at
the same time we don't necessarily want
to like
um you know play to the crowd and then
this
this is a moment where bannon's like no
we completely play to the crowd the
crowd is the only thing that matters
and um so i think he just recognized
that
and whether it was him just sort of
knowing that like he had this sort of
army
of trump supporters listening to am
radio 24 7
or if he was just looking at the
breitbart comments section as people
have talked about as well who knows but
he recognized this was emotion people
were coming to the
rallies and they were way more
passionate about trump than hillary
clinton
and he's like how do we tap into this
emotion and part of that is just
galvanizing people through memes
galvanizing people through getting angry
at the media
galvanizing people by telling telling
them that they've been lied to their
whole lives and they should be angry
about it and their anger is justified
and he did a pretty amazing job at um
leveraging that but critically
understanding also that we were in this
moment that
um you could sort of hack the media that
the way that
that the click-based media economy
worked and the way that twitter
and facebook worked is if you could just
kind of create these moments of reality
that the pace at which media now needs
to publish stuff and create clicks you
could basically
manipulate your own narrative right and
so that's that's really
the moment that that's that the moment
that trump tweets that smug pepe i think
is sort of like
the harbinger for this moment that we're
still kind of trying to make sense of at
this point but
if anything like the film is really a
story about
how these internet is realities folded
into real life and how we're still
trying to like make sense of what
is up and down yeah meanwhile the
the clinton campaign didn't seem to be
nearly as clued in
as to what was going on it was misstep
after misstep
uh you know on some level just blindly
unaware of how
powerful this culture was that was
sitting right beneath her feet yeah
that's actually like a perfect
moment for for what i'm describing right
you have this moment where hillary
clinton
has this big political campaign event
where she's going to
sort of call out the alt-right for the
first time and really call out pepe
right completely unrelated a kid on
4chan
happens to be attending this thing and
he's like talking with people on the
4chan threads like hey i'm at this
hillary clinton rally what should i
scream
and you know of course the media is all
there and they're all like oh you should
yell this or yell this and then
someone's like yell pepe like yeah yo
pepe yelp papel
this is all happening just on an
anonymous message board and like
it's this incredible event horizon where
like
the internet fiction meets with
real life and then becomes reality right
because what ends up happening is this
and he yells at the exactly right
right yeah yells pepe it gets picked up
by the tv cameras
hillary's talking literally about the
alt-right and before he
even mentions pepe at this point and
then like an hour later
uh rachel maddow's on msnbc talking
about like the pepe moment and then like
history is solidified at that point but
it all starts from like
a very trolly place yeah and and 99.9
percent of people would see that and not
know what to make of that at all
and yet it's so significant and
meaningful in that community
totally and it's really this moment that
like yeah politics ceases to be about
um kind of competing for votes through
ideas and really just about
uh trolling right like controlling
turns out is an incredibly powerful tool
to coalesce movements like if
it's literally just about honing the
libs and just making people angry and
the frog is a great way to sort of
uh yeah it's a way easier thing to
understand
exactly it's a way you don't have to
intellectualize the field exactly
you don't have to intellectualize the
feeling of piling on someone when
they're down
yeah and also hillary had been someone
who'd been the victim of trolling for
decades before
like you know the whole like feminazi
thing that was happening in the 90s
she'd been name-called and sort of
dragged
you know for years and years and years
and this was kind of the culmination of
that
and i think you know they i'm sure they
had all the best of intentions and what
they were trying to do they were
obviously trying to find a very
convenient and easy to understand way to
describe what was happening to the
republican party
and pepe to them seemed like a very easy
way to explain it
kind of the same way that we decided to
do it but
maybe much less nuance but what they
critically misunderstood was
what we all need to understand about how
to deal with trolling is like you can't
play
to the trolls right this is much to the
delight of people
like steve bannon that she did that
right right because you're just
because you can just point oh how
ridiculous is this person she's talking
about us like into this green frog
that's crazy you know yeah no matter
what you do it
plays into their favor and and so much
of the energy
has less to do with political ideology
than just like let's see if we can meme
this guy into the presidency
like it's it's gamified the whole thing
becomes a gigantic
um video game of mass participation
100 for sure yeah and like i think
unfortunately
you know what the past four years have
borne out is like you cannot
you can't build a society on that kind
of cynicism
right the kovid the things are real the
internet is not real things are real you
know it's real covid and you know what's
real is like not responding to it out of
a completely
grotesque cynical nihilistic perception
of like
how like society should
operate right and now we have like three
thousand people that does go back to
fortune i mean 4chan
would talk they would do these sort of
like they would coalesce to troll
someone in some way and they would talk
about how they're basically like gaming
reality yeah
you know and it was this sort of idea
that like we can try to like
use the internet to exert our will and
then that will maybe that's for the
lulls but in this case i think it was
very exciting to realize like oh wait a
minute we've sort of graduated to the
next
level of this we can actually like
gamify the system and troll the country
and um you know i i think the way that
they were sort of able to get all these
memes coming off of 4chan and then into
these very like
newly mainstream avenues on twitter
is something that was extremely potent
critically you had a group of people who
all felt
disempowered who also felt like the
internet was theirs that they created
internet culture
and now all of a sudden they're like oh
this is how the media works
we're actually in control of the media
we all have we have phds in this exactly
that level of disenfranchisement
suddenly becomes tremendous empowerment
like we were talking about a minute ago
like
now it and it's that it's that
trajectory from passivity
into being completely plugged in right
and participating not only participating
actually like you know being almost in
charge in some way
of dictating results well they literally
call it the memoir i mean it starts
again it starts off as a joke but like
you know they just it's cosplaying but
like ultimately at the end of the day if
that
if that's all that animates your life
like what's the difference between a
joke and reality i mean
they're viewing it in the same way we uh
we watched it again we watched the movie
again last night um
just to get my head around talking to
you guys today
and uh my wife i've got two boys that
are 24 and 25
so they're big redditers like they they
have a pretty
solid sense of all this is not news to
them right like they understand all this
my wife was like i don't understand
what's happening like
it's it is like a foreign you're tapping
into like some strange
you know ancient culture that you've
never been exposed to before that has
its own rules in its own language and
vocabulary
you know it's it's yeah 4chan is very
much about self-mythologizing
yeah did she understand it by the end of
the film well she gets it but she was
still like it's so baffling
right to try to wrap your head around
that if you've never been
introduced to these kinds of communities
and how powerful they are and that was
really a big struggle creatively was
trying to figure out like
who is the intended audience for this
film and then like
once we decide that how much how much
like explanation do we have to give
so that people can at least understand
what the hell we're talking about and
get
become engaged in the story yeah like
deconstructing that and figuring out how
to communicate
concisely and effectively this story
must have been
challenging yeah right it was
challenging but like
dark as the story was i mean the
collaboration was like
pretty joyful i mean it was something
where we felt like you know we
and we watched a lot of documentaries
when we started and we're like we don't
want to do that we want to try to do
something different let's try to like um
you realizing that we had all of matt's
artwork and pepe
as a way to kind of like breathe a new
era into this story because after
charlottesville there was all this
different media being put out
and we just kind of wanted to make
something that was like stylistically
distinct
and then also felt like a movie not just
like sort of a long-form
essay or you know a work of journalism
we wanted it to work like a movie so
we have all of these like this unique
material like pepe dies in the movie how
are we gonna
how are we gonna um approach that you
know is that something that we're going
to take seriously is it going to have a
wink like is it going to be all of those
things
and we knew that it could kind of give
this film its kind of own vibration that
we're
pretty excited about but yeah we
definitely like like giorgio was talking
about like the moment where someone
um yells pepe at hillary like we tried
that edit
a bunch of different ways and then the
first edit we did
we just had someone walking you through
the moment in a very like dry
journalistic kind of way and they're
like let's strip the voice out let's let
the internet
tell the story so we did that with no
narration and then it's like well how do
we put another layer of this where we
see that this information moves off of
4chan
pops into the mainstream news pops onto
youtube it ends up on twitter
and it was just kind of like oh we're
going to try to infuse these moments
with as much stuff as possible as many
layers to the conversation
because we wanted the movie to feel like
it had a viral intensity to it like you
had a million tabs open
and you were looking at the right one
after another right right right yeah
definitely
you've definitely succeeded and that i
mean there is
you know an intensity to it and and you
have a score that's very propulsive you
know that so you're very engaged and
there's a tempo to the whole thing but
it's also this beautiful art film
because the animation sequences are
insane like i mean unbelievable like
what you were able to achieve with that
like really gorgeous beautiful work
thank you yeah
yeah that was so talk about like how
that how you how you conceptualized that
and how you figured out how to make that
work narratively
that was another big thing that we
talked a lot about in the beginning when
we first thought about the movie
um we maybe thought there would be like
a lot more animation in it because we
felt like
maybe the story could hold a completely
other
sort of um kind of narrative uh thread
and that was going to have pepe and the
boys club kind of going on their own
adventure and we would hear them
talking and and they would kind of have
their own character qualities
and then we very quickly realized that
the movie just couldn't hold all of
these ideas
the deeper we got into researching
message boards and the message word
culture
we just realized that if we started to
insert
these cartoons in it it was going to
steal away from the power
of the information yeah and so we really
need to figure out a way to kind of like
have the two things worth side by side
but the other thing we really wanted to
do is make it seem like
matt's artwork had like a real um
sense of stage presence to it we didn't
want it to look like all the janky
jpegs and the animated gifs on the on
the internet we wanted it to have like
its own life
and um so that was something that
initially like i'd never made a film
before
um i'd done animation on a film that
giorgio had made called owned a tale of
two americas and enjoyed that process
and then i was like all right but this
is what i can kind of like try to bring
to the conversation
so the animation works in the film in
two different ways there's the world of
4chan
and the motion graphics and that was
really a way for me to research the film
like i had to take all these 4chan posts
find them and then make them 4k
so if i'm tracing them i'm reading 4chan
i'm down also make it right
like one of the ugliest websites on the
planet yeah it looks cinematic
taking a silkwood shower every night
absolutely so
and then the cartoon part of it i
collaborated with
three amazing cartoonists kailan woodrow
jenna caravello and nicole stafford
and we really took matt's comics as a
jumping off
you know place and sometimes we would
just trace his comics and
make them animated and then in other
times we would really kind of like
use these characters and then figure out
a way to kind of like tell our own
narrative
um and it was also just a way to kind of
make the computer
seem it was a way to tell feels good man
in a way where the computer didn't have
supremacy
right like it is a cartoon but
ultimately we wanted a story about how
humans connect
and um you know at the end of the movie
the hope
is that we as humans can have connection
to each other
at the end and um there's some spoilers
we'll avoid but ultimately we're kind of
returning
pepe to nature and as the animation crew
and also giorgio co-wrote a song with
sharon benetton for that section
um that was like kind of our gift to
matt and
our hope that the movie wouldn't feel
like this like
um dystopian essay you know that it
really had like a heart
the the closing sequence where he jumps
in the water and then
beautifully like swims up into the sun
and did you write that song at the end
i mean that's that's an
yeah it was uh yeah i mean it's the gift
of having animation be
a part of this it's also a realization
that it's really hard to end a
documentary
yeah that's true and so like like well
we have this frog
and people have an emotional attachment
to it let's create our own
emotional ride for pepe so that like at
the end
there was different versions of how we
were going to treat pepe but we always
knew that the last thing
that the audience would see would be
pepe because
our hope was if we were decent
filmmakers they would have their
a newly found emotional attachment to
our pepe
and that like that could produce the
waterworks
giorgio is very quick to cry which is
actually good
in the end i was like tearing up you
know it's a very beautiful ending but
there's also
a a real world uh hopeful
tone that struck at the end as well yeah
i mean
look that like everything we've been
talking about now has really just been
about
the impact that internet culture has had
on real life and this
the fact that like for years in the
early internet days it was very clear
delineation between
your real life person and your online
life and like these two things have
become really
blurred and we're at a moment now where
we have to decide as a society like
which reality are we going to push
forward right and the reality of the
internet is that it is a place at least
in its current
conception that teases out some like the
worst aspects
in us right it's a place where you're
encouraged to be
as shitty as possible to one another uh
you know and it's a place that like
discourages any bit of authenticity
and so the film the way we wanted to end
the film is a kind of
stark reminder that those are choices we
make right like you don't have to engage
the world in that way
and a reminder that like uh you
shouldn't be shamed out of your capacity
for empathy
which is kind of what social media does
to you on a daily basis
right and so those were the kind of the
emotions that we knew
the emotional truth that we knew we
wanted the film to end on and it was
just
without spoiling the larger ending like
we were given a real gift
in terms of pepe's transformation that
happened in real time while we were
filming that's like when you're making a
documentary film
you can't plan for this kind of stuff
and it's like such an amazing gift
yeah for sure so the film basically
covers about
two and a half years right from some
point in 2017 through
2019 there's a lot of focus on
on the the trump election as well but
here we are
in 2020 it's about to be 20
it'll be 2021 when this goes up knowing
everything that you
know now as a result of making this
movie and this archaeological dig that
you've done on the internet and how it
works
how do you reflect on the election that
we just
um went through and the state of
the internet currently in terms of how
we're communicating how it's being
weaponized and how people are conducting
themselves
to either you know win an election or
get their point across yeah i mean
the most obvious kind of parallel is q
anon because
in the same way pepe sort of started out
as this joke on 4chan
um and then made its way into the
mainstream q anon started out as a joke
on 4chan it was people sort of larping
as intelligence officers
and then all of a sudden this became
something that people were taking
seriously
um and so um you know the story
of of all of this message board culture
and trolling and stuff isn't
insignificant and that kind of
proves that but you know i think
the story that we kind of tell in um the
2016 election is how trolling went
mainstream and right now we're seeing
how misinformation has really gone
mainstream and obviously there's
they're connected um but it's something
that um
i think we're all um contending with
and it's something that i mean we've
talked a lot about we're having a moment
in culture where
all of the narratives that we've sort of
taken to be true are eroding
this notion of american exceptionalism
is something that people
are having to think about in a critical
way and that's really uncomfortable
for the first time for the first time
and so even if you
and that's you know the idea of america
being an exceptional place has
always been the thing that you know the
right wing in america has held on to is
something that's sacred
and right now through all of the
protests that we're seeing
the mismanagement of kovid we're seeing
that like whatever
sort of like sacredness you felt towards
america as being this special place um
is kind of something you have to
question and people are choosing to
believe in a fantasy
rather than engaging with a reality and
because you're on social media and
you're in these sort of siloed places
where you're not talking to people with
dissenting viewpoints
um you're being fed kind of new things
if you're into misinformation you're
getting
fed more misinformation um and also it's
very hard to parse what's real and
what's not
you know we're seeing kind of um
you know the intellectual fabric of
america erode and fray
and you know hopefully this is
pepe and the story of feels good man is
just like kind of a case study in which
we can all kind of start to have
conversations about this that's our goal
you know yeah i mean i hope the
the the film is kind of a youth culture
film certainly for people who are like
under 35 they feel like it's
um like there's much less translation
issues like they understand implicitly
what the story is about and it feels
like
a youth culture movie for their for
their generation but
it's been interesting to see older
people's reaction to the film
because i feel like for a lot of them
they feel empowered that they finally
understand what's happening in front of
them
in a way that felt really opaque and
unclear
um but like it's just
moving forward we just are going to have
to like realize that we have to
i don't know we've kind of incentivized
bad faith operators
and put them in charge of our in our
world and you have a media that still
seems to like take those bad faith
operators in good faith
and like that just has to stop right and
self-awareness around it
isn't enough like that's not part of the
solution like we can all sit here and
talk about it but meanwhile
it just seems like it's getting
ratcheted up like when you compare
2016 to now it's night and day and
you know the breakdown in our ability to
effectively communicate
and the distrust of information sources
and the uncertainty around what's true
and what's not true
and the you know disconnection that
we're now
experiencing because of the pandemic
like all of these things are
contributing to
a you know denigration of the moral
fabric of society
and i fear you know i have deep concerns
about how we're going to see our way
through this
even the people who are lording over
these social media platforms are
befuddled or insincere about
the path forward yeah i mean i feel like
tech has to sort of um come away from
this like
startup model or this kind of like boom
and bust model and think about
themselves more as like a public utility
where there has to be different people
sitting on the boards there has to be
ethicists they have to realize that
also you know this is affecting us here
in the west but in the global south it's
affecting people in an entirely
different way
you know in those places where there's
not as much um
sort of infrastructure this stuff is
also wreaking a different kind of chaos
and so um you know obviously we start to
ha
we have to have conversations where you
know we can't have just kind of like
the silicon valley boom and bust control
the reality of seven billion people
that's just not the way it's gonna work
but also the irony like i've never met
mark zuckerberg but i think he's
you know maybe not the most socialized
person so just the idea that like
our entire worlds are being defined by
kind of deeply anti-social people is
really
problematic but like the way that we
handle and confront these issues
needs to be taken much more seriously
like on twitter you know
every tweet at this point that donald
trump puts out has that stupid little
notification below it's like it's like
being standing in front of a tidal wave
right right it doesn't it doesn't it's
ineffective you just have to take them
off
and and like so many of the things you
talk about in the movie
it it perhaps is even playing into the
hands of his base
totally yes that just that just
energizes them
right to see that it's more us against
them yeah
yeah so they just have to you know you
just have to take it more seriously and
you know
i don't know to the extent that you have
to produce returns
quarterly returns for your investors
like i just wonder at what point
i don't know well the anonymous aspect
of the whole thing is
a big part of this right like does 4chan
exist
if you can't post anonymously right and
there's a
argument to be had that everybody who's
saying anything on the internet should
get a blue check and be verified so that
you can
basically legitimize who these people
are and yet
you know i had brian fogle in here
talking about the dissident the other
day and how important it is for
dissidents to be able to communicate
from a safe place and that requires some
level of anonymity
in a place like saudi arabia where 80 of
the population is on
is on twitter and the only bastion of
free speech
is twitter because it's decentralized
and can't be
you know lorded over by the control of
the kingdom yeah i used to think
verification was
a certain path towards you know
positivity
but i will say like on all the social
media platforms
probably the worst comments we get are
on facebook oh my god like i'll just
click people's
you know it's a photo of a guy with his
family his two kids
from valdosta georgia who's just saying
like the most depraved worst about
our film possible
it's like oh maybe have you gotten a
bunch of negative blow back like that
i mean if you look at the comments on
youtube or on facebook they're pretty
predictable
but i have to say the in in terms of
like our personal engagement with people
it's been the opposite like um we've had
actually a lot of people
reach out and say that the movie touched
them in some way or they've been
spending a lot of time on 4chan maybe
when they were a teenager
and they're in the process of maybe
aging out of it and the movie spoke to
them in a really positive way
um you know i also think like you know
even pepe in the media has shifted since
we completed the film
pepe on twitch is basically like the de
facto mascot for twitch he's back to
being a reaction image where people are
like excited or happy or angry
so if you're on twitch and you're
looking at the comments field you'll
just see like
you know chunks of pepes floating by
nothing to do with like white supremacy
or anything yeah just
for yeah so yeah it's each platform kind
of has its own
relationship take on things but no we
felt like actually
we obviously had some understandable
fear while we were making the film
but the reality is this is a
conversation that people are kind of
ready to have and a lot
of that like intense feeling that people
had about pepe
kind of evaporated during 2016 and 2017
and this is something that um it's time
for us to all have a conversation about
it because
um you know it's something where
culture's experiencing and we have to go
through it together
right so you premiere the movie at
sundance
which is super dope like this is like
you've made one
one movie prior right this is your first
this is the first film that you've been
involved with
or right so that's super exciting right
you guys are young guys you make this
movie you get into sundance you go you
get
yeah yeah turn out standing ovation you
get you win this award
yeah no it was amazing i mean also we we
got into sundance with like storyboards
so a lot of like the animations were
just like chickens
essentially wow and so we were just like
sprinting
sprinting to get the film done yeah but
i don't have everybody say that's like
some of my favorite memories from the
process
is those kind of like sleepless insane
nights right
um yeah that was like very emotional
like there was one night where i was
like i think it was like
five in the morning and we had like
we're trying to mix the film the next
day and it was just me
and our assistant editor caitlin in the
office and i just told kayla's like
um i'm going to start to cry right now i
don't know what else to do
you're just going to watch me and i'm
going to sit here and cry for like an
hour while we're editing
and assembling things because it's such
like this emotionally
kind of intense experience um sundance
obviously was like a dream come true but
then once you're kind of there you
realize there's all these other sort of
like
other people with dreams yeah too you're
just you're one of many people
and you also have to finish the movie
and then like throw a wedding for the
movie at the same time because you have
to like
have a party and you have to make sure
the party's at the right time so people
will come
and it's like yeah it's this really kind
of um
very fun and surreal but incredibly
stressful
thing and then also we're trying to like
sell the film so it's kind of we're
trying to present ourselves as like oh
this is a product that we made
please buy our products yeah
yeah it's a experience you're going with
the best of intentions we're like
packed house which theater did you
premiere at
the pioneer the pioneer yeah on a monday
yeah like a monday monday
monday morning so it doesn't matter what
day it is when you're there
though well it actually does it does we
found it i mean if well
if you want to you want to be at the
egyptian on friday night or whatever
yeah i mean the big sales all happen
in the opening two days right and so
like i think
we recognized well as soon as we found
our monday slot that like
okay i was like you though i was like oh
we're just at sundance
this is right everything is gravy this
is this is amazing
but then it's like people are like well
so and so can't come and
they might be interested in your film
because it's monday morning specifically
oh man the psychological so yeah people
are just sort of
people are just sort of chipping away at
your enthusiasm as you're kind of going
into it
and um you know i don't know i'm also
like i'm a very like
kind of private self-conscious person
like like red carpet stuff is like
uncomfortable for me for sure
and so um there's a part of me that's
also like well how am i gonna become
like i'm an animator i'm i'm used to
like being behind the computer in the
middle of the night
animating i'm not used to sort of like
standing up and talking confidently and
selling a film
so that was like a pretty heavy
experience right
you know i discovered the movie uh i
heard somebody talking about it and it
just lodged in my memory
and so you know a couple nights later i
searched for it
i found it on amazon i rented it i
watched it
but i did have to look for it right it
wasn't front and center
in my netflix queue screaming at me to
watch
and you know as i said at the outset
like i i really feel like this
you know this is a movie that everybody
should see um but i do think that
that it's suffering from a lack of
visibility and discoverability so can we
talk about like the distribution aspect
of this whole thing
i mean we agree that's part of why we're
here like i wanna i wanna i wanna help
you get you guys out there a little bit
now the conversation yeah
yeah i mean we created our own like
distribution company basically
to distribute it we self-distributed the
film so we created a company called
ready fictions
in part because um you know we did go
into sundance
and we'd heard a bunch of different
stuff people that were interested in the
film
but i will say like this was always a
hard movie to convince people to get
behind
and so we were able to make it
independently which was great because we
found
i mean shout out to wavelength
productions they're an independent
company and they saw
some early cuts of the film and they
always believed in us to make the movie
and they have like been very supportive
but they were supportive in a way that
like
certainly none of the platforms were
supportive and a lot of the other more
established companies
that um we presented the film to and
some in some cases you could feel like
people slowly backing out of the room as
you were pitching the movie
because pepe has this just knee-jerk
reaction when people see that frog
they're like oh man
you know even one of the programmers at
sundance she was like
you know i had all these movies to watch
for sundance and then it was like the
pepe the frog movie
oh man and then she watched it and loved
it right um
but that's been like a pretty common
refrain and then when we went to sell
the film
we had a lot of the same kind of moments
yeah it's hard
it's hard to know i don't know obviously
i'm sure there's like certain levels of
assurances that distributors want to see
right you can pitch an idea
you know the idea might be interesting
but they want to see it finished right
so like
when we were pitching the film people
were like you guys have never really
made a
film of note before yeah it was
understandable and it was understandable
then we make this film it's like we win
this award we're like okay
we proved it like it's a great film it's
getting great reviews
so like all right now now the offers
certainly should be writing and then
it's like crickets and then you're like
you're never getting a really
clear answer from the streamers
who have like now kind of totalizing
monopolistic control over
what people see you're not getting a
sense of like why
they're passing on it but you know i
don't know i would love to talk to
someone about it because there was
we would get the the information we
would get was like they really liked it
but
it just wasn't a fit you know yeah i
mean well that's the issue is that
that's not that's just generally
disingenuous i mean we were talking
about this before the podcast and
and this also goes back to a
conversation i have with brian fogle and
the struggles that he
um has undergone trying to get his movie
out there because
after winning an oscar right he wins the
oscar you know
netflix that's those are that's his team
and they won't touch the movie
amazon you know basically there's a
whole backstory to that and he thought
like well bezos will want to be on board
with this because
the subject matter they passed and you
realize that
there's a big difference between getting
a domestic theatrical distributor who's
going to put the movie in some theaters
in the united states
and a streaming platform where it's
instantly globally available
and these gigantic conglomerates live
and breathe
on expanding their subscriber base in
foreign territories and when
you look at saudi arabia and you look at
china anything
that is transgressive to those cultures
becomes
radioactive to distribute right it's
just not worth it
it doesn't matter how good your movie is
like if that's going to cause
some kind of adverse reaction in those
communities or the political powers that
be
it's just not worth it to them they're
not they're going to pass on it yeah and
as
as the industry pushes more towards a
subscription-based model i would assume
that like the stakes just become much
different right if you're
universal and you're putting out uh a
film theatrically that's maybe
edgy people can boycott that film
they're not boycotting universal
but if netflix puts out a movie that
they maybe aren't sure how it's going to
be received and maybe has like a high
level of
potential for blowback and people
boycott the subscription it's like
you know right i can see how yeah the
stakes are much higher but
all the same it's also it's really
scary to think as like an independent
filmmaker and storyteller like
as these as these platforms consolidate
their power like what it
does to and you know coming out of covet
and seeing what's going to happen to the
theatrical market like right that's
really
like you like you said without theaters
basically independent cinema
doesn't exist right you kind of have to
prove yourself in movie theaters
as a viable thing it's also harder if
you're a young filmmaker
because there was always this sort of
like independent model or even if you
had like a small theater police or
with a tiny you know sort of um company
you would still have kind of a way into
the industry and so
that's kind of actually getting harder
even though there's more stuff
and i think just realistically like
documentaries
um are kind of at this transitional
phase this year
some of the best films or documentary
films and they're breaking genre
they're doing very interesting things um
and
these streaming platforms really only
care about documentaries that are about
like some of them are obviously news
oriented but then it's celebrities and
murder
right and so having this story where if
you have this
tile of a green frog on your platform
you don't know which algorithmic
sort of base that is going right yeah
yeah and so we were told it was like too
niche we were told that um
it was too political china definitely
was something like at the end of our
movie there's
the china became like something that
scared some platforms away
um and then also it was just like they
were like oh well we already have
x movie or y yeah and so
people would never watch both of those
or the fact that it might have its own
materials about two movies about uh
what was the party in the caribbean oh
yeah the fire
far right at the same time right yeah i
know
well what was fascinating i wish i wrote
it down because i i can't remember
specifically what they were but
when we when we finished watching the
movie and
amazon shows you you know people who
watch this movie also like these movies
and trapper who is you know my my uh
24 year old he was laughing he's like
these movies have nothing to do with
that movie like it was a weird
like assemblage of bizarro films and
that's the the great irony is as
like you're like you're kind of psyching
yourself up like all right we're gonna
do this we're gonna self-release our
film and like
our eps are on board and like that's
incredible and everyone believes in this
thing
and you're like you know the system
we're gonna do this stuff on our own
then yeah and then suddenly you realize
that like you have to give jeff bezos
yeah he takes half of every rental right
half of every right right right yeah
it's like apple pass
they're they're going to take your money
no matter what bezos passes the amazon's
going to take you back yeah and there's
this moment where you're like like
for instance one distributor offered us
zero dollars for the film and then they
would they would commit to x number of
marketing spend
and that seems like offensive it's to me
it seemed like well this sounds like i'm
going down like a payday loan
sort of scenario down the street but
they can do it because they know the
path to sells to distribution
is so difficult and so we kind of
thought that like
well we made this movie independently
like you know
we we have this kind of like mixed
resume so like let's just do it
ourselves so something where it's like
all right
we can cut the trailers we can make the
animation we can figure out the strategy
during this covid moment we know as well
as anybody kind of how to get the film
in him
yeah and like the way that matt leaned
on his friends to help him out we
really have a lot of thanks to give to
our friends
and friends of friends who really got
behind the film like and even honestly
it was a very
meager little theatrical release but
like tim league at alamo drafthouse
i just sent him a cold email as we were
kind of contemplating this
and he emailed back like almost
instantaneously and was like i'll help
you however you want that's cool
yeah and like at all of them or just the
one and every one of them could have
opened
in september yeah so we had like 12
screens but you know
that was super meaningful when you're
like wandering off into the wilderness
the people that go to that place are
that's your audience totally
so i don't know hopefully like if things
get better soon then we can get back
into the theaters there but like
those are really meaningful moments that
kind of reassure us that we're
doing the right thing that people give a
because at the end of the day
like people are just in and to your
point like it's hard to find it's hard
to find because
there's just so much out there yeah
good yeah there's some good
there's also a lot of but like
you have to sift through all of it and
there's two
morons at our own office like trying to
figure out how to make this happen
like it's it's a daunting task but like
slowly but surely it's
um you know i think it's you know a
testament to this
right the film itself is that it just
gets passed on the the streaming
platform thing is
is is fascinating and how it's kind of
uh
being accelerated through this pandemic
moment i mean on the one hand you know
when netflix
in the early days of netflix it's like
this is the greatest thing that ever
happened to a documentary filmmaker
suddenly all of these films that
would never get a theatrical release or
if it did it would be in one art house
movie theater for a week or something
like that
now are being consumed by millions and
millions of people
and yet you have to uh you know
take in a consideration at the same time
that there is
this weird implicit chilling effect on
free speech
when they're not going to platform films
that are transgressive in any way that's
going to threaten
the the broadening of their subscriber
base and what is that how does that
bode for the future right you can always
get it up
like you guys did but it does become a
challenge to get people to
to see it and we were lucky i mean we
had the film is about a viral phenomenon
so we knew that we kind of had pepe as
like our best sort of
right advertising chip for it there was
all those people that care about that
hopefully we knew we had that as an
audience but i think for
for other films that for whatever reason
you know don't get picked up by just
like the four or five people who are the
gatekeepers for the entire industry
um it's it's a harder path because you
have to convince people to
um get behind the film you know with
without having the most popular meme
that's ever been
right uh on the poster right brian was
talking about
the idea that's crazy to hear about
brian the dissident was being edited
while we were doing color like i was
watching the stress
involved with that yeah i can't i can't
imagine i mean yeah the the
the computer graphics animation
sequences in that movie
i mean very different from yours but
also you know kind of amazing have you
seen that have you seen that
i haven't seen the final cut i mean yeah
they were in the same color house
right so it was all the films that are
going into sundance are
the same place so we're it's all like
two in the morning we're passing in the
hallway
i didn't see brian but um i saw one of
his producers yeah um but he had
his idea was that there's a need for a
new
streaming platform to serve these kinds
of movies that
isn't about you know constant growth
that
can create some kind of revenue model
that makes sense
and makes it robust and and profitable
yeah um
but the priority being kind of you know
getting movies like this out that
that aren't going to be that are going
to be challenged in another way the
truth is that there are like
so many unbelievable documentaries that
just that
will premiere at festivals like sundance
that never get picked up and just kind
of like
get lost in the shuffle yeah and the
whole world
verite document yeah like there's a
genre of doc that doesn't get picked up
by the platforms at all and it's just
the verite
style which is just sort of like letting
life unfold in front of the camera
and you know like there's this movie uh
the mayor that people should seek out by
david ositz who's about and that movie
is about the mayor of ramallah in
palestine the christian mayor of
ramallah in palestine
and that movie um is an example of
beautiful
edgy you know verite filmmaking
and you know those kind of films don't
make it onto the platforms and in part
because documentary
is kind of having a a secondary growth
moment
and um you know documentaries have kind
of always been funded as if they're kind
of like charity cases
they're funded by sort of people who are
like wealthy and this is almost like a
donation they're making
but the reality is you're right like
there's a lot of amazing films getting
made
and there needs to be like a platform
for them where people recognize like
the the financial potential and like the
artistic potential in them
right yeah i talked to a software
company who's interested in backing
such a thing in terms of
the grand lineage of donating to the
cause of documentaries
exactly yeah yeah we're ready to do it
we've no it's because we've been
thinking about the same thing completely
because like the information that we've
gleaned from
self-releasing like we want to be able
to teach other people how to do it
because
it is daunting but it is completely
doable you just have to know what to do
especially like
if the only thing that's kind of hard to
know for people who care about you
yeah yeah yeah and all at the end of the
day no one's gonna care about your movie
more than you
of course not so like yeah in many cases
the best option really is i mean that
was a big mistake i think i made with my
previous film owned
uh is just like selling it off to the
first person who was interested in like
kind of shooting myself in the foot
rather than having done it myself
but that's discouraging considering he
did so well with
you know yeah but i mean i just you know
the the the
it just speaks to the um you know
tension around the subject matter of the
film for sure which you'll
you'll appreciate when you see it yeah
um
we got to talk about the archdruid
i'm not letting you out of here until i
hear the story behind
that dude because i mean
how did you even find this guy like what
an unbelievable character
well i mean before me magic was
something people talked about on 4chan
so
for months before we found him
there was just a a card on the on the
bulletin board that was like me magic
question mark
explain what magic is all right
you made the movie yeah well so we
talked about earlier how fortune likes
to self-mythologize
right and anytime you can see these
coincidences or stuff it just
it just regales and delights in any kind
of sort of coincidences that happen in
real life that they've kind of been
talking about and so me magic
i don't know you're better you're doing
it so b
magic is basically uh specific to pepe
you know they already have an emotional
connection to pepe someone finds out
that like
uh there's an ancient egyptian frog god
uh who's the god of chaos and he's an
anthropomorphic
drug and his name is pepe no his name is
keck his name is sorry
keck but of cacao i mean people yes
all right but people on 4chan have
always kind of taken memes more
seriously than the rest of the culture
so you know and let's let's kind of like
broaden the definition of memes not just
sort of as like an image macro the way
pepe is or a cartoon but even like
something as simple as make america
great again or a catchphrase or an idea
that sort of filters out through culture
your feelings that's a
just that's a meme excuse me just do it
these are memes
and so 4chan has always kind of
considered themselves to to take this
stuff
important as important and realize that
it's powerful
and to realize that kind of um they also
recognize that they're like a community
that has
power with each other they're a
congregation of people
and if they're sitting in front of the
computer for 12 hours a day
looking at this stuff there is putting
out into the world
there is kind of this quasi-religious
projection that's happening
so people on the boards will talk about
memes as being important and then memes
also having like
um some sort of esoteric significance
like these are symbols symbols are
important
they have history and so me magic is
something that people would talk about
on the boards
kind of half as a joke but half as a way
to like self mythologize
and give importance to themselves and so
when they started to use pepe they
realized oh pepe is sort of like
our signifying meme he's sort of like
our god
oh and then there is a pantheon of
egyptian gods and one of them is a frog
and he's the god of chaos and we're a
bunch of posters
who want this chaos to like you know you
know disseminate through culture and so
people started to make all of these um
pepes that were kind of a mix of just
like
historical religious iconography a lot
of it from egypt but a lot of from other
places too
and of course this fits in with like the
illuminati and all the sort of stuff
right
and pepe just kind of became this other
like kind of like focal point
for this kind of discussion that was
happening and so people would talk about
like these moments we were talking about
where pepe gets yelled at the
rally in reno or the moment that hillary
falls
because people on 4chan have been trying
to like basically
put it out into the world that that
hillary should be sick and have this
kind of medical event
and these are moments of like kind of
strange confirmation for them
and so um people would talk about this
as being mean magic or chaos magic and
so
initially we wanted to um find someone
that could talk about this though
from a greater historical perspective
that would give the idea some gravity so
that it wasn't just someone
who's talking about posting in kind
of a
aggregate you know self-aggrandizing way
and so um
but also also in a way that's like humor
like
in the style of the film too right
because you're talking about me magic
you have to accept the fact that it's a
bit absurd but you also have to accept
the fact that it's also like i don't
know it's like kind of true
kind of interesting yeah i think the
connections are kind of funny
uh and then yeah i just i had happened
to done a podcast about my previous film
and
at the end of the interview they asked
me what i was working on next and we
were trying to be
mum about the project and i just said
vaguely that we were doing a film about
pepe
and someone who listened and i think i
got mad at him afterwards i was like you
got to shut up about that
yeah that's actually very specific
yeah and then this uh this guy emailed
and was like hey if you're doing a movie
about pepe you should read
the work of this guy john michael greer
who
is an archdruid and i googled him and
the first image that pops up is him as
an archdruid and he's got this
incredible beard
and i'm like oh boy i pushed he was
wearing a ceremonial
dress yeah and i sent it to arthur and
then we started reading his stuff and
listening to him on radio like
this guy's actually like pretty
incredible and really
brings a kind of seriousness and
intellectual honesty to the topic of of
magic really and he gave us a really
incredible definition of magic which
really fits in very neatly to what
the story is about right magic is about
sort of
people you'd say it better than i always
well i mean
he's sort of quoting this um this
occultist named dion fortune right
and he's sort of an acolyte of hers um
but yeah they sort of talk about
obviously it's sort of all the trappings
of magic that seems a little bit like
hocus pocus but this other thing they're
talking about is much more serious
and that's the idea that magic has
always been the politics of the unheard
that if you are magic proliferates and
sort of happens within communities where
they don't feel like they have any
agency in the world that they live in
so it happened in like feudal situations
it happened it happened among slave
cultures where people didn't feel like
they had
agency in their own reality and so they
would kind of create
ceremonial ways of like art and
willpower
trying to affect their reality in a
positive way
and also give them hope and so um you
know
he talks about pepe as being a hyper
sigil that people are sort of pumping
energy into
and as we were talking to him there was
a moment where you're making a film and
you take chances on conversations you're
going to try out a voice in the film so
we interviewed a lot of people
um and they didn't make the cut and then
when we interviewed him um
there was just kind of this like
vibrational shift that happened in the
room
and it but also amazing fascinating
i was gonna say also because like we had
to go up to providence to meet him
where arthur went to school and he
happened to know that this beautiful old
library
exists there where edgar allan poe
apparently i had no idea because there's
like a dude
you got a risd yeah i went to rose d and
there's there's a decrepit fountain
in front of it and um the joke would be
like you'd be coming out of like a party
and you'd be stumbling home and you'd
stumble past the library and if you
drank from this decrepit fountain it
means that you were gonna die
in providence and so there was always
this thing where it's like oh you get
drunk did you drink from the fountain
it means you're gonna die here but
providence has this like creepy witchy
kind of vibe anyway right it's got h.p
lovecraft it's got edgar allen poe
and there was this like little private
library very near the campus of risd
and um and uh supposedly edgar allan poe
had a crush on the librarian
and he wrote some of his like final
poems there so he could just kind of
like basically
creep out on her but um so we were able
to film that with john
and um but john initially um
you know we booked it and we didn't have
much money so we booked it at 10 a.m
and i was like all right john you got to
get there at 9am because it's cheaper
and john was like that early no no no
like
i won't be up until six or seven i'm
nocturnal yeah you're nocturnal
and so we ended up spending a little bit
of more money
to to film him at night but it just kind
of elevated the whole thing
into like a v it also just we we've been
doing this run of like
interviews and i think we were kind of
feeling like tired and then that just
kind of reinvigorated the whole total
yeah yeah i mean i think within five
minutes of the interview like i was just
covered in goosebumps and i just walked
out of the library to go to the nearest
liquor store to buy a really nice bottle
of whiskey because i was just like
i knew we had it because it just his
presence of the film is
the sum total of everything we were
trying to achieve with the film which is
riding this line of
utter complete stupidity and at the most
like serious
right important yeah conversation
because there's an absurdist
total aspect of the whole thing but
actually what he's saying is powerful
and he's
such a great sport about it too like he
was very self-aware of why he was there
he gave us incredible he was only a
30-minute interview he was unbelievably
efficient and like what he was able to
do but also like
was really uh helpful and like leaning
into the jokes like he let us do this
little
but he also gave us like he kind of
brought another kind of
um idea into focus when we were editing
the film and that was this moment
you'd sort of talked about matt brainard
earlier where it's like he presents
himself in a certain way
and so while we were making the film
we're like all right let's give the
audience these moments where they have
to decide where we're coming from and
whether they're choosing to take this
person seriously
and so with john michael greer it's this
kind of like litmus test thing when
people watch the movie
a lot of people are like um i don't know
the movie kind of the documentary went
off the rails in that moment i don't i
don't know why they inserted this guy
and then other people are like oh that's
my favorite part and it's also matt
fury's favorite part
that's not surprising yeah yeah yeah but
um and that was kind of part of it too
it's like
who who would be kind of the voice for
this for matt and it seemed like he was
the right dude yeah
but um but it's this kind of like lean
in moment where it's like all right what
are
we wanted the audience to be like all
right am i taking him seriously why did
the filmmakers choose to put him in
there
it's this moment where it's like are are
are
our audience members going to feel like
engaged with the subject matter in a way
where they might choose to disagree with
us for a second and then come back to it
and we thought that was kind of like a
very interesting interesting device to
use
yeah well i mean he's certainly a guy
that i'd like to have
around once in a while to call on for
you know like
it would just be cool to have that guy
in your circle but beyond that
what i took from what he had to say was
that there's
power in group consciousness like you
can call it meme magic but when you have
millions of people
whose mental energy is aligned in a
certain way and they're trying to
manifest a certain
result like that's something that you
cannot overlook like that's a hugely
powerful thing because
that translates into the behaviors and
the actions that those people are going
to take
yeah completely and then we're talking
about how this frog
just caught the imagination of a group
of people so
yeah the occultist is going to bring it
all into view yeah
how do you i look at this movie in
certain it's very different from
this other movie that i was going to
mention but they kind of um
are like cousins in a way like how do
you think about the social dilemma and
how this movie fits in with that one
like i feel like those two movies could
be watched
back to back as companion pieces to each
other
yeah i mean i think i think they're
both i mean as we've talked about media
literacy i think the social dilemma is a
super effective film especially if
you're like a young person who maybe
hasn't thought
about your phone in a critical way um
and so i do think that like i mean
that's why they'd be so great if they
were sitting next to each other on
netflix
right i do that which they should be
yeah
i mean i mean tristan harris was on uh
dax shepard's podcast recently and dax
thankfully thank you dex
uh uh he mentioned your phone that might
have been where i heard it first because
i listened to that anything
oh yeah but then tristan hadn't seen it
yet which is like a real bummer it's
like
come on man well i think it's good that
these these
i i think it's good that a lot of people
are watching these kind of movies
because i do think that like like we
were saying before social media is
something that we have to be critical of
as a culture
and we have to realize how we are all
susceptible to this kind of like machine
learning and the echo chambers that we
find ourselves in and so obviously
his move like you know the social
dilemma kind of tackles that
a little bit more head-on and our movie
is kind of like a little bit more spread
out it's got this artist journey story
mixed with this kind of cultural
critique but um you know i do think like
giorgio mentioned that you know feels
good man is a little bit of a youth
culture movie i think they both are i
think they're movies that are gonna kind
of like
um kind of open people up to a slightly
different way of
of understanding how they ingest social
media and i think that's really good
you know and i also think that if you
liked the social dilemma you should read
the books of douglas rushkoff
why is that because those guys are
repeating what douglas ruskoff says
yeah in his book like throwing rocks at
the google bus
so and there's always been kind of you
know douglas ruskoff represents this
voice of the earlier kind of internet
critique
and that critique has always also been
kind of like bundled into this other
notion that this could be like an
economic revolution as well
in that there can be a more peer-to-peer
version of our economy
and we're having this moment during the
pandemic where it's like we're
discovering
that our economy which seems in some
ways to be doing very well
like the the stock market is doing very
well that our economy doesn't need
workers anymore it only needs consumers
and it's this other model that in order
for all this stuff to change we have to
realize that some of the economic
underpinnings of our culture have to
shift and change and that's going to be
a slow
and kind of painful process but
ultimately it leads to
kind of hopefully a more democratized
system that we can all be part of
but we're just realizing that that has
to be like intentional
that we have to like um start to make
decisions and realize that this is not
going to be like
you know it's not going to be the matter
of a couple social media platforms
changing their sort of you know flagging
of truth or conspiracy
that it's going to be like a series of
like
smaller very intentional decisions made
over a long period of time
by a bigger group of voices in order for
this to really change
you know silicon valley does have to
figure out a way to be more inclusive
because it
is like it's ultimately like affecting
cultures across the globe and it needs
to reflect that
it needs to have like more diverse
voices in those rooms
and i think that um ultimately we're in
a transitional moment
right now and that if we sort of are
able to understand the truths that like
the social dilemma holds or
feels good man points to that we can
have like a greater intentionality over
this that we can sort of like
um um not give in to the machine
learning and realize that we have kind
of the ability to
to have the world be a better more
humane more
human place because of the internet
and so i think we're just at this moment
that's really confusing and i hope we
pass out of it
but yeah i mean that's that's very
beautifully put
and i think a good place to end it but i
can't end it without
bringing it back to matt um
and i think what strikes me the most
about him
is you know despite the fact that he
goes on this journey and he has these
emotional peaks and valleys
he never loses sight of his core value
which is to be optimistic
and to always kind of double down on
love right
it's like he ends the film by saying you
gotta go hardcore happy
and that's you know clearly the message
that you want to
leave people with but in order to get
there we have to you know experience
this
you know this this very cynical
situation
that you document this garbage world to
use
matt's work to use matt's words um
but ultimately you end up you know in
this in this kind of hopeful
place right so is that how you look at
this now
like were you able to you know go
through this whole process
and and come out of it optimistic about
the future
i mean i think you have to be because
that's how trolling works right
it only works if it strips you of hope
and
and subjugates you to the the idea of of
cynicism
and so you know the reason we wanted i
think when we
first interviewed matt you know he said
that hardcore happy
sentence and then maybe in the context
of the interview it felt maybe a little
hippy dippy but then when we placed it
at the end of the film
it kind of imbued it with a level of
power that i wasn't personally prepared
for it always kills me every time i
watch it because there's kind of a
wincing when he says it
because like depression is obviously a
very real thing
and can't be dismissed but there's also
a truth to how you engage the world
and that there's choices you make about
that and
matt's choice is hardcore happiness and
like if you don't
make that choice you're kind of like on
a path towards
the basement right and that's what one
of our characters kind of represented
and
i think he he's someone who feels
trapped
the person the basement person he feels
trapped by a machine that he feels like
he can't get out from under
um so i don't know i think
i i totally subscribe to the hardcore
happy
[Laughter]
it's not hippie dippy because i think
like georgio was talking about this
wincing
moment he's talking about the the look
on matt's face when he says it
and it's this moment where you know matt
does have this sort of acknowledgement
that this is a
choice and that um it's a not an easy
choice to make
and it's a choice that constantly takes
like recalibration within all the sort
of things that are happening
um throughout your day um you know but
we do
think that the movie our hope for it is
that like
you know anonymous people on the
internet have used
pepe anonymously and you kind of imagine
that to sort of all happen within a
vacuum but the reality is there is sort
of a ripple effect
and so if you um see the way that the
use of pepe has affected matt
and his family if you see if you were
able to kind of observe that maybe
they'll just be like this
like subtle kind of um shift of
perception that you have
and i think that that's was kind of our
our goal
in in the end of the film and i feel
um i don't know i'm some i'm someone
that
has i felt hopeful just from making the
film
um from working with the people who were
so passionate
while they were making the film those
collaborations are
actually have like kind of reinvigorated
me um
you know i don't know how i feel about
the future of social media though that's
something that i don't know if i have
the same sort of optimism but
i'll keep that to myself are you guys
are you guys on social you're
are you on social media yeah i am he's a
twitter guy
you are okay um we'll end it with that
but
uh what are you working on now like
what's next for you guys
well we're still in the we're still in
the rivet hall yeah but you can work out
some things
yeah yeah yeah no maybe you don't want
to talk about it i don't know no that's
fine we're working on an animated series
we're developing with it with a comedian
that
i think has a lot of hope hopefully and
writing projects um
i think we're going to take next year to
really like
generate new ideas but if anyone wants
to hire us
but you guys are working together now
right yeah cool
that's cool well it's a powerful duo um
thank you thank you very much i really
appreciate this yeah
like i said like i love the movie it was
better the second time
watching it the other night i can't
stress enough how everybody who's
watching or listening should check it
out
please do the best place to do that i
mean there's
feel feelsgoodmovie.com right feels
feels good
feels good man i really butchered that
didn't i
i got that totally up it was a
valiant effort we appreciate it
um but you're on amazon obviously you're
on
apple tv i just disappointed because
i didn't know this until we self
released but so amazon takes 50
of the take and apple takes thirty
percent
wow go forth go watch it on
tv then those two places though right
and everywhere a lot of vimeo it's a
bunch we have a link tree on the website
so cool
and if you um want to connect with you
guys individually you're on social media
yeah right we're both on instagram you
are yeah i think you have to be
so excited about that not being coy it's
just a private account but i'll probably
accept you yeah yeah
yeah yeah but we we we you can email
through the website we
respond there's no yeah we've had we
have we have a lot of conversations with
people that have watched the movie and
um they're always fascinating yeah cool
well best of luck you guys thank you so
much for you if there's anything else i
can do
thanks thank you man that means i really
appreciate it all right peace
[Music]
you